[Music]
she's my real Wonder Woman I'm so proud
of you tonight
Wonder Woman director patty Jenkins
presenting gal gadot with the hashtag be
her award at the 2018 Critics Choice
Awards
I used to one to save the world it's
only the second time the award has been
given
Viola Davis was last year's winner the
accolades spotlights more accurate
portrayals of women in film throughout
my career I was always asked to describe
my dream role and it was clear to me
that I wanted to portray a strong and
independent woman a real one and all of
these qualities I looked for I found in
her she's full of heart strength
compassion and forgiveness she commands
the attention of the world and in doing
so she sets a positive example for
Humanity and want to share this award
with all the women and men who stands
for Rutte what's right standing for
those who can stand or speak for
themselves a superhero film also won
best action movie on Thursday night but
otherwise the film and its director have
largely been snubbed this awards season
vt spoke with Jenkins on Tuesday here's
what she had to say about getting
overlooked by the Golden Globes for a
directing nomination and what became an
all male category look it's been a
little glaring that women directors
don't get nominated particularly when
their films are being celebrated in
every other way we also talked with
Godot this week
she says female led movies shouldn't
have to be fought for but I think that
you know having movies that are female
and is not charity work it's like it
proves itself in the box office and we
are 50% of the world so why wouldn't we
have 50% of the movie female a led